COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS.
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING THE TELECONFERENCE RVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATING TOLL FREE NUMBER
ANDACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
YOUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT FOUR ONE ZERO
THREE FOUR NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. S. IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE. IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
OF CAUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING THE
HEARING AS A AS IS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE AND
SUPPORT AND THEIR CONNECTIONS
WILL BE MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIME.
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF ON
LINE TO THE TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD AND WE
THANK YOU. AND I WILL BEGIN
THIS MORNING IN THE QUORUM.
BEFORE WE CONTINUE TODAY'S
AGENDA LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE MEMBERS
TO TURN ON THEIR MICROPHONES SO
YOU CAN BE HEARD- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETA
IT'S A LETTER HERE GROWTH.
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE MELENDEZ
NEWMAN NEWMAN HERE ROTH AMBERG.
NUMBER CARE YOU HAVE A COURT WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU THE
CONSULTANT KNOWS THE QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED AND- WE HAVE
SEVEN BILLS ON THE COUNTER
TODAY FOR OUR AND CONSENT DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- CENTER NEWMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MOTION. AND AGAIN
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
SHOULD YOU WE CAN HEAR YOUR
VOTE- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARCHULETA HI. I GROWTH
EGGMAN RIGHT EGGMAN AYE
MELENDEZ NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE
ROTH AMBERG HERE BY BOTH BURKE
AT THEIR END I. OKAY WE HAVE A
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR RULES.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE BONDS BILL WE
HAVE FOUR. COLIN THAT. CHAU
WOULD BEGIN OKAY LET'S SEE GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
AND- YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE ZERO ZERO
TWO. THANK YOU CHAIR. SENATOR
ATTILA- IT IS SOME MY PLEASURE
TWO PRESENT DAHLE A. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO. HI AB ONE ZERO
ZERO TWO US SIMPLY REQUESTS-
THE UC. AND DIRECTS OTHERS SEE
US YOU TO FORMULATE THE ON A
CONSISTENT POLICY IT'LL
RECOGNIZE SUCH A MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBERS SO JOINT
SERVICE SERVICE- JOINED NOT
GOING TO SERVICE OUR
TRANSCRIPTS AND FORWARD
APPROPRIATE OF COURSE CREDIT.
FOR THE- PRIOR RECORD SHOT AND
THE OR TRAINING. YEAH BONTA
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASTOR S. B. ONE OR
SEVEN. INTRODUCED BY SENATOR
RICHARD- ROTH- CREATING THE
MASS OF THE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO TO
RECOGNIZE THE JOINT TO SERVICE
TRANSCRIPT FOR TRANSFERABLE
ROUTE CREDIT DUCKED INTO
DEGREES PATH. SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCEDURES SHE
HAS HAD TAKEN THE STEP ON THE
SYSTEM FOR YOU TO IMPLEMENT
THIS SMALL. THIS BILL LAW A. B.
ONE ZERO ZERO TWO BILLS UPON
THE FRAMEWORK DEVELOPED BY U.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY ONE TO APPLY
TO THE UC AND CSU IN ORDER TO
BETTER. SERVE THE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION VETERANS SO COOL
CORE CALIFORNIA HOME AND DON'T
WISH TO PUSH THROUGH THE OHIO
EDUCATION CHORUS THROUGH AB.
ONE ZERO ZERO TWO. VETERANS AND
A SERVICE MEMBERS SO WOULD
RECEIVE A ZERO DO YOU CREDIT UP
IDEA CENTRES SILVA HI YOUR
LEARNING AND THAT THEY HAVE
BURNED OUR DURING THE MILITARY
SERVICE THIS BILL PASSED OFF
FOR. A IN CONSENT IN BOTH
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR THIS
REASON IS- I RESPECTIVELY ASK
FOR YOUR HI VODAFONE AB ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MEMBER DO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS AND
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE A TIME
LIMIT ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE FERMENTED THREE
MINUTES. ALL OTHER WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO- ANYONE WANTED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. AND WE DO
WE DO NOT HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS ON AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO
WE WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM.
TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO WE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES-
HANDED CHAU- THE SERVICE SO WE
HAVE NO ONE ON THE PHONE
MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE. IN SUPPORT BY- IT
IF YOU'D LIKE YOU LOOK FOR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO END
UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS TIME. SO
ONE MORE TIME IS- READY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WOULD YOU
ASK ONE MORE TIME. JUST
REMINDER IS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. OKAY THANK YOU. OF THE
ALBUM MOVED TO ROOM- TROUBLE
THREE ENTERS FINEOPPOSITION
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. AND IN
TWENTY FORTY. IN OPPOSITION.
SHE NINE- MODERATOR YOU HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. THAT WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. JUST
A REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
US NOW. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
SOMEONE COMING UP AS WE SPEAK
TO BE JUST A BRIEF MOMENT.
MODERATOR FOR US ONE MORE TIME
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. AB. ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO. CERTAINLY JUST
REMIND ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF
YOU'RE QUEUING UP FOR
OPPOSITION IN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO WE DO HAVE LINE ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I WAS CUTE
AT FIRST THE COURT BUT THEY
DIDN'T RECOGNIZE THIS IS THE
WORST RAN FOR US FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION OR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE'RE OKAY FOR ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WILL
KEEP WILL KEEP IT OPEN THAT WAY.%
NO. NO FURTHER LINE'S CUTE
MISTER CARE. NO THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL A- SENATORS LET
ME TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. HERE.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- ASSEMBLY MATURE
THANK YOU ROOMS BILL I ACTUALLY
IN THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF SB
TEN SEVENTY ONE- WHICH I
INTRODUCED- AND IT WAS ACTUALLY
A TRANSFER TO SEND A ROTH.
WHILE I WAS ON SABBATICAL. MY
DAD WAS ACTUALLY CONTINUATION
OF ANOTHER BILL AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY TWO- DENNISON WOMEN- DAN
EVENTUALLY CENTRE MARC BLOCH.
THE IN TWENTY TWELVE STARTED
THIS PROCESS OF SEEKING TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND THOUGHTFULLY
GIVE VETERANS BACK CREDIT FOR
SERVICE IN EDUCATION THAT THEY-
HAVE THEY GOT IN THE MILITARY
SO AND YOU KNOW GLAD TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL HERE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AS IT MOVES THROUGH- AND GLAD
TO HELP IN ANYWAY THAT I CAN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CORRECTION
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU OF
CENTERS. CENTER GROVE YOU HAVE
COMMENTS YES PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MY APOLOGIES FOR
BEING DELAYED ADDED ANOTHER
COMMITTEE BUT- I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
IN THE FUTURE IF YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING UP
THE BILL FORWARD. YES PLEASE.
GEN ROBERT. THOUGHT I WAS GONNA
MOVE THE BILL BUT- THEN I HIT
PAUSE. AFTER HER THE CENTER
NEWMAN WAS THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR
OF THE BILL. SO NOW I'M- SORT
OF ON THE FENCE BUT ANYWAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. SOME
NIGHTS RIGHT. OKAY FOR THE
RECORD CENTER NUMBER WILL BE
MOVING THE BILL- IS THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I
HAVE A PROMOTION FROM CENTER
NUMBER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE. IN FACT MEMBERS
STRONG AND DIVERSE EFFECTIVELY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE WORKED AT. WE
HAVE A MOTION- LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BURKE FIRST
BE REEF RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ARCHULETA. AYE GROVE AYE GROVE
AYE EGGMAN HI HI MELENDEZ
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT I ROTH NUMBER
I THANK. THANK YOU FIVE ZERO
BUT WE CAN HOLD IT OPEN FOR.
FIVE I N. ZERO NO. CAN WE LEAVE
IT OPEN THANK YOU LET'S GO ON
TO THE NEXT BILL. WHICH IS A J.
R. TEN. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
YOU MAY PROCEED- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SANTA BARBARA A TO
LANA AND THE MEMBERS SAW. THESE
2% EIGHTY J. R. TEN ONE
IMPORTANT A STEP TOWARD THE
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE KOREAN
SOLDIERS SOME MADE IN THE
VIETNAM WAR BY URGING CONGRESS
TO GRANT THOSE- KOREAN VETERANS
SO FOR NOW I'LL TELL YOU AS A
CITIZENS OF BEVERLY HONOR RIGHT
SO. THAT THE STATE SPEND ON
NATIONAL CEMETERIES A. G. O.
TIENEN WAS- JOINT AUTHORED BY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON COOKSON
RAW AND THE CO AUTHORED BY
SENATOR DAVID MANN. AS YOU KNOW
HONORABLY DISCHARGED VETERANS
THEIR SPOUSES AND THEIR
DEPENDENT CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
BURIAL IN VETERANS ARE
CEMETERIES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TO EXTENDED THE BURIAL. AND IF
IT'S- IN NASH. VETERANS AS A SO
TO. MALL RAFI SO WHO IN
AMERICAN BACK UP CAN'T RELY YOU-
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR AND- WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME NATURALIZED
OF UNITED STATES CITIZENS. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE UNITED
STATES- THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA
PROVIDED A MAJOR MILITARY
SUPPORT WITH APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND.
REPUBLIC OF KOREA AND- US
SOLDIERS SERVING IN VIETNAM
BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
REPUBLIC OF KOREA FORCES SO FOR
THE TEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO- ARE INJURED AND UP.
FIVE THOUSAND NINETY NINE
KILLED IN ACTION DURING THE WAR
THE PROXIMITY AT THE SAME RATE
DOT BOOK CAPITA IT DOES SO IT
U. S. OF COURSE ISN'T. I
BELIEVE A IT IS ALMOST A
FITTING TO ALLOW THE- REMAINING
NUMB WERE VETERANS SO- NON US
CITIZENS ARE TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
BURIAL IN ANY STATE AND
NATIONAL. VETERANS OF
CEMETERIES ACCORDING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SO THIS IS
SAW SIMPLY THE JOINT THE
RESOLUTION AND AS SUCH LEAVES
IT UP TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
SO TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO
APPROVE EXTENDING IN TURN MONTH
BENEFITS UP TO THEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ALL TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT JOINT THE RESOLUTION
TO HONOR OUR BRAVE UP KOREAN
SOLDIERS SO WHO FOUGHT
ALONGSIDE THE- UNITED STATES.
ARMY BYE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON
AJ ON TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO- ANYONE WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A J. R. TEN- AND
THERE IS NO PRIMARY WITNESS FOR
A J. R. CAN. WILL MOVE- TO
ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANYONE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A J. R.
CAN. THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
TESTIFIED BY PHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF A J. R. TEN WE WILL BEGIN.
CERTAINLY ONCE AGAIN YEAH YOU
UP FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE ASK ONE MORE
TIME AND SUPPORT AJ ARE. TEN
CERTAINLY ONCE AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO QUEUE UP IMMEDIATELY IN
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU JUST
HAVING HEARD- LET'S SEE THERE'S
NO NO ONE IN SUPPORT LET'S GO
HADN'T ASKED FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE ANYONE
IN THE WITNESSES ROOM OF TWENTY
FORTY AT TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
H. A. R. DAN. NO THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO ANYONE TO
TESTIFY VIA TELEPHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AJ ARE. TEN
CERTAINLY ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO QUEUE UP IMMEDIATELY IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE CUTE AT THE
MOMENT MR CARE MODERATOR ASKED
ONE MORE TIME IF ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION TO A J. R. CAN. STE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUED UP IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU WATER IT I WILL NOW. GO TO-
OUR SENATORS- FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CENTER ON BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER CHOI
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I
HAD SERVED IN KOREA FOR A YEAR
ON THE DEMILITARIZED ZONE AND
NEAR THE DEMILITARIZED ZONE.
AND WAS WITNESS TO THE COURAGE
DEDICATION AND THE PERSEVERANCE
OF KOREAN SOLDIERS AND I
BELIEVE CAPTAIN NEWMAN ALSO
SERVED IN KOREAN PROBABLY FEELS
SIMILARLY TO THE WAY I DO
CONCERNING OUR OUR KOREAN-
ALLIES A COUPLE CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS. IN THE IN THE
RESOLUTION IT SAYS- THAT THOSE
WHO WOULD SAYS VETERANS WHO
SERVED IN THE VIETNAM WAR DO
YOU MEAN THOSE WHO SERVED
ACTUALLY IN VIETNAM OR JUST
THOSE WHO SERVED. DURING THE
PERIOD OF THE VIETNAM CONFLICT.
ORDERED DUSTUP CAREER DOT COM
FROM MONTY. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BUCKS
AS THE NUMBER INDICATED GO OVER
A THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR. DEPOSIT
TWENTY THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE SO
FOR THOSE ALL WHO HAVE
IMMIGRATED TO THE U. S. I. HAVE
BECOME NATURALIZED US CITIZENS
AND THE HORN DAY PASSED AWAY
HERE THOSE ARE THE LIMITED
NUMBER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT
SO IF YOU SERVED IN THE KOREAN
ARMY DURING THE VIETNAM WAR BUT
YOU SERVED ON CITY UP ON THE
WITH OLD SO WHO SERVED. IN
VIETNAM ALONG SIDE ALL FOUR U.
S. OKAY SO ONLY THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY SERVED IN THE COUNTRY
VIETNAM YES SIR ALL RIGHT IT
COULD YOU CLARIFY THAT WOULD
YOU MIND. AMENDING IT TO
CLARIFY THAT. BUT YOU KNOW
NOTHING BUT CLARIFY THE THIS
RESOLUTION. APPLIES ONLY TO
THOSE WHO SERVED ACTUALLY IN
VIETNAM YES IT DOES. OKAY BUT
THE LANGUAGE IS NOT CLEAR SO
WHAT I'M ASKING IS ARE YOU
AMENABLE TO AMENDING THE BILL
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT YOU'RE
ONLY REFERRING TO THOSE WHO
SERVED. IN THE COUNTRY VIETNAM.
FOR I DON'T HAVE THE- SPECIFIC
CAR ACTUALLY EXPECT ORDER. THE
RESOLUTION IS SORRY HERE RIGHT
I COULD REDO THE PHRASE YOU CAN.
IF YOU HAVE INFORMATION. INTENT
INTENT WAS SELF APPOINTED THOSE
WHO SERVED IN VIETNAM
PHYSICALLY RIGHT AND I'M NOT
THOSE SO DURING THAT THE ANY
SOLDIERS WHO SERVED IN THE
KOREAN ARMY AND THE STATION
DAWKINS IN KOREA AND MYSELF
ALWAYS SO. LIEUTENANT AUDIT
SERVED UP BUT TALK OF OUR UNIT
WAS NOT CALLED UPON TO GO TO
VIETNAM SOUL I WOULD NOT BE
QUALIFIED I SEE OKAY SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS IT READS.
KOREAN VETERANS WHO SERVED IN
THE VIETNAM WAR AND MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS WOULD YOU AMEND THIS
TO CLARIFY THAT YOU ARE
REFERRING ONLY TO THOSE WHO
SERVED IN COUNTRY YEAH IF THE
OF RESOLUTION. HAS NOT ALREADY
MENTIONED. YES SORRY IT WAS TO
ON A NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR LOOKED
UP THAT DEMAND MONTH APARTHEID
I STRONGLY BELIEVE ALREADY TELL
LANGUAGES SPECIFIES THAT THAT
WAY. ALL RIGHT. ON THE SECOND
QUESTION IS THAT- DURING MY
SERVICE IN KOREA WHICH WAS
QUITE AWHILE AGO THERE ARE
STILL A NUMBER OF. KOREAN
SOLDIERS WHO HAD SERVED DURING
THE KOREAN WAR AND I KNOW MANY
HAVE IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES SO WHICH WOULD YOU ALSO
AMENDED THE RESOLUTION TO
INCLUDE. THOSE KOREANS WHO
SERVED IN THE KOREAN ARMY
DURING THE KOREAN WAR AND NOW
HAVE IMMIGRANT UNITED STATES
AND ARE US CITIZENS WOULD YOU
CONSIDER EXPANDING IT TO. THOSE
KOREAN SOLDIERS WHO FOUGHT
ALONGSIDE BLOOD ALONGSIDE U. S.
SOLDIERS DURING THE KOREAN WAR
OR- FOR. THE INTENT IS NOT TO
NOT TO BECAUSE OF OR OR- WHY SO
PER TO THOSE OF WAS. IN VIETNAM
BUT THEY IF YOU'LL- INCLUDE
THE- KOREAN WAR VETERANS SO-
BUT PASS A KOREAN SOLDIER
DURING THE PERIOD TALK- I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE SO HAPPY
BECAUSE OF. THE SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER ALL OF THEM HAVE
IMMIGRATED TO AND BECAME THE-
CITIZENS OF THE U. S. SO IF
FOR. KNOCKED OUT THE NOT- THE
JEOPARDY SAID THAT THE PASSAGE
OF ICE ON TEN I MEAN DOT DO YOU
WANT TO COME. AMENDMENT ANNOYED
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THE DISTINCTION AND YOU'VE
CLEARED THAT UP THAT THAT THERE
SHOULD BE NO DISTINCTION
BETWEEN. SURE NOT THAT THAT WE
MADE A LOSS THAT THE SINCE. THE
KOREAN SOLDIERS TO SACRIFICE
ABSENT ALLY ALL OF OUR U. S.
ARMY U. S. A SOLDIER SO. A
SEVEN BOARDS THIS THE SERVER TO
GATHER OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
CRITICAL OR VIETNAM WAR AND-
DAYS- SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
DOCILE DAS WARI. THE DESERVE UP
TO HALF THE BURIAL RIGHT THE
BOTTLE WHEN YOU TRY TO EXPAND
IT TALK- FOR KOREAN CONFLICT
OVER WHO WHERE THEY DEFENDED
THEIR OWN COUNTRY EVEN SOUL US
SOLDIERS ARE CAME ALONG WITH
FORTY DENTAL. SO IF YOU EXPAND
THAT. A CONCEPT THE U. S.
SOLDIER OF ALL ALONG WITH
KOREAN SOLDIERS DO IN THE
KOREAN CONFLICT. TALKING
ALREADY IT IS SO MORE WELCOME
BUT IT DOES NUMBER ORDER ORDER.
EXPAND US ON MAY BE. OUR I MEAN
ALL THE WAY TO COME NOT
AMENDMENT- BUT THOUGHT WE COULD
TREAT IT US SEPARATELY LATER IT
FOR TELL CERTAINLY DECIDE YEAH
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY SUCH A
DESIRE EXPRESSED. BY KOREAN
SOLDIERS. WHO FOUGHT DURING THE
KOREAN WAR. THANK AM TRYING TO
IS THAT IN THE MAIL YOUR
ACCEPTING TO INCLUDE THOSE.
YEAH OUR GLADLY ACCEPTED ALL
RIGHT YEAH IN AN I SEE IN YOUR
BILL ITSELF IT IT REFERENCES
THE NUMBER OF IT REFERENCES THE-
FACT THAT ACTUALLY VIETNAMESE
SOLDIERS. L. NUMBER KOREAN
SOLDIERS SO WOULD YOU CONSIDER
ALSO. MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
VIETNAMESE SOLDIERS WHO FOUGHT
SIDE BY SIDE BY KOREAN WITH
KOREAN SOLDIERS THE NUMBER OF
UNITS WERE TOGETHER KOREAN AND
VIETNAMESE UNITS WORK TOGETHER
THAT IS WELL AS US UNITS THAT
THAT THOSE VIETNAMESE SOLDIERS
WHO HAVE NOW EMIGRATE UNITED
STATES IN OUR U. S. CITIZENS IT
MAY ALSO BE INCLUDED. OR ATM BY
OLDER MEN SAW IN ALL OF THIS
WAS SO BECAUSE TO US ALL ON A
NON WHISTLE SENATOR DAVID MAIN.
ONE ARE OF KOREAN DESCENT
STUFF- AND ON THE SENATE AND- I
WAS THE ONLY ONE- KOREAN
AMERICANS SERVING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. SOL I KNOW
PRESENTE DA AND TAIYO. KOREAN
AMERICAN ARE INTO STATE THAT
AND I KNOW TO. ALL A PART OF
REQUESTS AND- SO REPRESENTING
KOREAN COMMUNITY BUT THE I DO
NOT THINK OFF OFF VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY AND DAHLE IF YOU
EXPAND IT UP THERE AND ALL I'M
I'M SURE VIETNAMESE OF VETERANS
WHO ARE LIVING HERE AND WILL
BECAME THE U. S. CITIZENS SO
THAT WATER WATER COME THAT
IDEA. OKAY SO ARE YOU AMENDING
THE BILL TO INCLUDE VIETNAMESE
AS WELL YES SIR ALL RIGHT- AND
ALSO- CURRENTLY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF. AFGHANS WHO ARE
IMMIGRATION UNITED STATES SOME
WHO BECOME CITIZENS ALREADY
WOULD YOU BE AMENABLE TO
INCLUDING AFGHAN. THOSE AFGHAN
SOLDIERS. A MILITARY PERSON WHO
FOUGHT ALONGSIDE U. S. IN
AFGHANISTAN WHO EMIGRATED TO
BECOME CITIZENS WOULD YOU
CONSIDER INCLUDING THEM AS WELL.
I WONDER WHERE THEY ARE. HI
SHOULD THE GOAL OUR PHONE.
FALLECIDO VON MARI ORIGIN OR
INTENT OF BONES NATASA BOUNDARY
BECAUSE IF WE STOP DOING THAT
TYPE THING BECAUSE IT IT IT IT
IT IS- NOT THE ORIGINAL INTENT
OF THIS BILL- SO ANY ANYONE
NOW- WHO AREN'T. ALWAYS SERVED
ALL ALONG WITH THE U. S.
SOLDIERS HAD SIDE BY SIDE
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR ONE SO
ONE BUT THE WE EXPANDED DOCTOR
TO THE KOREAN WAR BUT THE IF WE
START DOING THAT. ALL THE WARS
THE CONFLICT OUT- IS YOUR
NORMAL YOU AS A SOLDIER SAW CAR
IS LAW OFFICES SO IF SO. THAT
MEANS THAT IT. IT IT IS SO
BEYOND THE MY IS OF ART AT THIS
TIME I SEE SO KOREANS WHO
FOUGHT THE KOREAN WAR IN
VIETNAMESE NOT AFGHANS RIGHT.
YOUR VIETNAM THEY ARE. VIETNAM
SOLDIERS SAW I NEVER SPOKE WITH
SUNDAY NUMBER OF FORTUNE. BUT
I'LL ASSUME SINCE SO WE DO HAVE
ALL SUBSTANTIAL REFUGEES FROM
VIETNAM WHO SERVED AS A
MILITARY SOLDIER SO HELPFUL
BECAME THE U. S. CITIZENS SO
THAT WOULD NOT COME TO BECAUSE
SO OR YOU KNOW INTENT WAS SO-
OF VIETNAMESE SO. CONFLICT OF
THE SO WHO SERVED THE U. S.
SOLDIER OF TASK WHY I A VIDEO.
SO MIGHT BE- EMBRACEABLE
HOWEVER. OUTSIDE OF THAT AREA
SINCE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
KOREAN YES A SOLDIER'S SOUTH
KOREAN WAR MAY BE- BOOKS
OCTOBER. BUT DR ANY ANY OTHER
COUNTRIES OTHER THAN A KOREAN
WAR VIETNAM WAR- YES SO
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE PLO-
WILL BE DILUTED SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M AFRAID OF. THE THERE'S A
VERY FAMOUS MEXICAN UNIT THAT
FOUGHT MORE WORK TO THE
NECKLACE ALSO INVITE THE AZTEC
EAGLES THEY FOUGHT WITH US IT
MORE WAR TWO. AND SEVERAL WERE
KILLED- WHAT WOULD YOU INCLUDE
THE MEMBERS OF THE MEXICAN THE
AZTECS EAGLES WHO FOUGHT WITH
US THE OTHER THEIR MEXICAN
NATIONALS TO THE EXTENT THE
NAME AND BECOME U. S. CITIZENS.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER INCLUDING
MEXICAN I'M NOT MEXICAN
AMERICAN GIRL YET THEY ARE
MIXING AMERICANS UP MEXICANS
WHO FOUGHT. WITH THE AZTECS
EAGLES. IN NOW ARE YOU IS.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THEM AS- I'M
NOT THE REALLY. FAMILIAR OR
MEXICANS. SO WHO- SERVE TO WITH
A U. S. SOLDIERS ASSAULT
JUSTIFICA AFGHAN CONFLICT- IT
IT COST OF. ABOUT BEING BEYOND
THE SCOPE ALL REGION HONORS
SCHOOL BALL MY AGE A I TEN SO I.
WOULD RATHER. PREFER TO THE-
MAN OF THE WE HAVE I HAVE
AGREED UPON ONE LOCAL KOREAN
ON- WORLD CONFLICT TO SOLDIERS.
WHO CAME HERE ARE- AND OF
VIETNAMESE SO WHO SERVED ALONG
WITH A U. S. SOLDIERS SO AND
WILL BE TENDER YES OR YES OKAY
SO THAT'LL JUST LARGEST
EMPLOYER AND I'M MORE FOCUSED
ON MIND IF I INTERJECT FIRST
ONE TO REVIEW THE BIDDING- LET
ME LET ME JUST FINISH OKAY SO
WE'VE GOT. KOREAN WAR VETS YES
WE'VE GOT THOSE TWO KOREANS WHO
FOUGHT VIETNAM WE GOT
VIETNAMESE NO AFGHANS NO
MEXICANS RIGHT DAUGHTER THE
DAUGHTER OF THE A LOT THE
SIMPLER AND DOT. PLOT LINES
WITH MY ORIGIN OR INTENT I'M
SURE WE CAN- SOMEBODY OUT OF
CELL SOME MORE. INTEREST THEY
CAN- PICK UP THE DAIS MODEL
ONCE WE PASS THIS ONE BECAUSE
OF THIS OP AJ ON IS SO ON THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE CONGRESS
TO. ACT UPON. HI SENATE IS
EMBODYING THE WILL OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AS TO WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE THE CONGRESS TO DO THIS
ALL RIGHT SO IN YOUR IN YOUR
ALSO AYE I SEE THAT THERE ARE.
THREE THOUSAND KOREAN AMERICANS
WHO FROM YOUR POINT OF VIEW.
UNDER THE ORIGINAL BILL WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY UNDER THE
EXPANDED VERSION OF VIETNAMESE
AS WELL AS KOREAN BUT THERE ARE.
THREE THOUSAND WHO KOREAN.
PRIMERA WHO EMIGRATE NIGHT
STAYS BECOME YOU CITIZENS. SO
DO YOU HAVE ANY ESTO OF THOSE
FOR. WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
MORE BUT OF THOSE THREE
THOUSAND WOULD WANT TO
EXERCISE. THAT OPPORTUNITY BE
BURIED IN A VETERANS CEMETERY I
DON'T KNOW NOT TAKE. ANY RISK
ABA BEING WRONG BECAUSE I HAVE
NOT PAID ANY ATTENTION. AND
VETERANS SO WHO WERE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED. IN THE KOREAN WAR.
THEY ARE PROBABLY QUITE H. THE
N. NOT MOST LIKELY UP IN
NINETIES AND THE HOW MANY OF
THEM ARE STILL SURVIVING S. R.
U. S. AS CITIZENS SO. BUT I
WOULD SAY THE ARE PART
ELIMINATED THAT NOT THAT MANY.
OKAY SO IN TERMS OF THE
CEMETERIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
YOU'RE AWARE THAT THE CEMETERY
IN WEST LOS ANGELES NATIONAL
CEMETERY. NO MORE NO MORE
BURIALS THERE IT'S FULL RIGHT.
IF YOU'RE NOT I JUST DON'T GIVE
YOU THAT FACTOID. SO IN ALSO
THAT. OTHER CEMETERIES ARE
QUICKLY FILLING UP ARLINGTON
FOR EXAMPLE- THEY ARE
CONSIDERING RESTRICTING BURIALS
AT ARLINGTON. SO IN TERMS OF
THE THAT. THAT'S WHY I'M
INTERESTED IN THE NUMBER OF.
BILLS THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE
UNDER THIS CRITERIA. INTO THE
EXTENT THERE'S LIMITED SPACE DO
YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF SO FOR
EXAMPLE TO CREATE AMERICAN
WHO'S CURRENTLY SERVING IN
AFGHANISTAN RIGHT U. S. SOLDIER
CURRENTLY SERVING IN
AFGHANISTAN. IN TWENTY YEARS
FROM NOW MAYBE. MAYBE IT MAY BE
IN NEED OF A BURIAL SPOT HOW
MANY OF THOSE HAVE ANY SENSE AT
ALL HOW MANY CURRENTLY SERVING
OR U. S. VETS BOB WOULD BE
PRECLUDED HIM ANY SENSE AT ALL.
NO I DON'T OKAY. IN IT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT- YOUR
COMMUNITY REPRESENTED BY YOU
KOREAN AMERICANS WELL CENTER
MEN CREATE AMERICAN. A NUMBER
CREATE AMERICAN SERVING ON THE
IRVINE CITY COUNCIL RIGHT. BUT
IN IRVINE THERE'S BEEN A EIGHT
YEAR PROCESS OF SELECTING A
CEMETERY IN IRVINE A VETERANS
CEMETERY IS THAT RIGHT YES. AND
THAT PROCESS HAS TAKEN TIME AND
I THINK WE PUT. AT LEAST A
COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS INTO
THAT HAVE WE NOT. AND THEN NOW.
IS I UNDERSTAND YOU SUPPORT A
CEMETERY IN IRVINE RIGHT YES I
DID ALL RIGHT GOOD BECAUSE
THERE'S A MOVEMENT TO KILL THE
CEMETERY IN IRVINE I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE. YOU SUPPORT THE
CEMETERY IN IRVINE VETERANS
CEMETERY. YEAH I DID THAT BUT
DON'T WORRY ALL RIGHT RIGHT
NOW. WHO PROBABLY ARE WE ARE. I
BELIEVE- ABOUT A WEEK AGO. ZERO
IRVINE NOT CITY COUNCIL TOOK
UPON THAT. MATTER TO CHOOSE A
BETWEEN- TWO SIZE BEST QUALITY
N. B. R. N. DA OKAY PHOTO
ACCORDING TO THE NEWS AND I-
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES I READ STUFF
IT WAS A VERY CONTENTIOUS-
DISCUSSION FOUR AND HALF HOUR
SON TO TURN THIRTY. IN THE
MORNING AND ALL SO MANY
RESIDENTS ARE TEAM AND ALL WE
DON'T WANT TO. AND ALL THE
SPEAKER OF THE SPEAKER SO THAT
TOOK A LONG TIME AND ARE THERE
FOR A CITY COUNCILS TO PROMOTE
NONTON ACTION NOT. TO ATTACK
AND THEN ENACT. IN A DECIDED
NOT TO TAKE AND ALL. I RUN THE
PEOPLE BEFORE. THAT CITY
COUNCIL OR- DELIBERATION NOVEL
WHICH SIDE THE WATER- PUBLIC
ON. ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS
ASSOCIATION LEADERS EXPRESSED-
VIDEO ANNOUNCEMENT. BUT THEY
USED A WORD DOC WE ONLY MEMBER
I I'M GOING TO INTERRUPT YOU
SENATOR- BURKE CAN WE KEEP THAT
BACK BACK DOWN TO AJ ARE CAN
AND KEEP THAT CONVERSATION
THERE PLEASE. B. OPERATORS
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT I JUST
WONDER WHERE THESE FOLKS ARE
GONNA BE BURIED BUT BUT I THINK
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU DO
SUPPORT A CEMETERY IN IRVINE IS
THAT RIGHT. I DID TALK ABOUT
HOW WHENEVER I DO SUPPORT
TRANSACTION CEMETERY IN POLLING
TODAY VETERANS SO THEY
PREFERRED. TO GO TO ANAHEIM
HILLS. AND BECAUSE THEY I HAVE
A WHOLE. BECAUSE IRVINE. SAN
SAW- FOREVER DO YOU GO. TO
KITCHEN POSSIBLY SOLDATEN MAY
PREVENT THEM TO SEE
ACTUALIZATION OF A VETERANS SO
THAT THEIR OWN SOCIAL SITUATION
VETERANS OF THEMSELVES ARE
THIRTY ARM ALL RIGHT NOW MOVING
ARE TRUE AND I'M HERE ALSO AND
AS I UNDERSTAND THE SUPERVISED
WITHOUT BOND WEGNER IS A
MEETING. JULY FIRST ON. NINE
THIRTY AM AT THAT SITE. TWO OR
NO OF THE SO PER DOT FOR AN I'M
HERE SO THAT IS SAW- THOUGHT
HE'D AWAY. THERE WILL BE I
SORRY COMPONENT OF WHAT THE
DEBORAH. OF A CEMETERY IN
ORANGE COUNTY EITHER SIDE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE AN ORANGE
PARK IN IRVINE IF THEY PREFER I
AND I'M HERE SO I SUPPORT THAT
NO I'M WHAT I'M ASKING YOU IS
GIVEN THAT YOU'RE- EXPANDING
THE NUMBER OF. INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE GOING TO BE BURIED THERE
LEAST ASKING TO BE BURIED IN
VETERANS CEMETERIES AND THAT
THERE'S A LARGE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN IRVINE IN MY RIGHT
YES THE- AND- THAT'S WHERE
WE'VE SPENT TIME AND EFFORT
STABLING CEMETERY I JUST WANT
TO UNDERSTAND DO YOU SUPPORT A
CEMETERY IN IRVINE. NEAR WHERE
THE KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
CREEK WHEN THERE'S A LARGE
PORTION OF CREAM AMERICAN
COMMUNITY OUR SUPPORT TO
WHEREVER- ALSO PRACTICAL AND A
VETERANS A ONE DOLLAR. RIGHT
NOW WITH THE TREND US IT
APPEARS TO ME I'M NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN WHICH YOU OF I CITY
COUNCIL AT THIS TIME NATIONAL
LAW SO THEY ARE- TAKING AN
ACTION PLAN TO. MOVE THE
INTERESTED TO AND I'M HERE SAID
IF THAT'S THE CASE I'LL
DISAPPOINT THEM. BUT EVERY
INTEREST ONCE AGAIN GERMAN I
I'D LIKE YOU AGAIN EARNERS LAST
QUESTION FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND
H. A. R. TEN IF YOU LAST
QUESTION WHAT WOULD YOU
CONSIDER AMENDING AG ARE TEN-
TO. REQUEST A STUDY. TO FIND
OUT EXACTLY. WHAT THE NUMBER OF.
IN NOW THAT WE GOT. CREE
AMERICANS FROM THE CRANK
VIETNAM IT IS WELL AS
VIETNAMESE DO TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MANY WOULD BE BURIED IN STATE
AND NATIONAL CEMETERY SO WE
COULD FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE IN THE FUTURE IN
TERMS OF DISPLACEMENT OF THOSE
WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN THE U. S.
MILITARY WOULD YOU AMEND YOUR
BILL TO PROVIDE FOR STUDY SO WE
COULD ACCURATELY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE IMPACT IS GOING TO BE
A ALREADY- WOULD BE WILLING TO
INCLUDE THOUGHT THOSE SAW- NEW
CATEGORIES TO WHAT PEOPLE
HOWEVER- COMING UP WITH THE
BEST MATE- A GOOD EDUCATED GUN
NUMBER OF ALL VIETNAMESE
SOLDIERS SO WHO HAVE BECOME SO
THE CITIZENS HERE. AND THE
WORLD- I WOULD HAVE TO REACH
OUT TO THEIR COMMUNITY WITH A
THEY HAVE ANY FIGURES SO WHAT
ANY. STATISTICS IS THE THAN
THAT NONE NATIONAL HONOR-
ORGANIZATIONS OF LIKE A CENSUS
BUREAU MAY HAVE COME AND GONE
AGAIN NOT A KOREAN CONFLICT THE
VETERANS HOW MANY ARE CURRENTLY
SURVIVING AND- IN THE U. S. SO
SIMPLY TO ME IT WOULD BE- FOR
THOSE SPECIFIC KAVA PROCEDURE
AND A TIME. ONCE WE PASS THIS
ONE SOME. MAY CHOOSE AND THAT
AND THAT THEY HAVE TO BE A- LAW
INFORMED ABOUT THAT THEIR
ELIGIBILITY SEOUL PART TO ME-
IT WOULD- PARKED UNDERNEATH
TEDA BUT THE COMING UP WITH THE
ACCURATE NUMBER FOR THIS TO BE
INCLUDED AND ALL OF PRESENTED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR IT WOULD BE
IN TIME WHY SO IT WOULD BE
UNREALISTIC BUT THE I WOULD. BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU- SO WE
HAVE A FOUR THE KNOWLEDGE THE-
PEOPLE BUT TOP MY GUESS IS
STILL QUITE. TIME WHAT THANK
YOU I PER THE OPPORTUNITY I
WOULD SUGGEST AND TO HAVE SO
HAN ON THAT. THAT WE PUT THIS
OVER TO CONSIDER IT IN FOR
EXAMPLE IN JANUARY OR LATER ON
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
UNDERSTANDING AS TO WHAT THIS
IMPACT WOULD BE. IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO DO THAT. I PREFER TO
HOW TO BE PASSED ASKED CALL HAS
TO DO SO AND THE MAYBE WE CAN-
WORK ON NOT AN ADULT VERSION
WHAT WE CAN INCLUDE THE U. R.
SUGGESTED THOUGHT AMENDMENT THE
LANGUAGE IN THERE AND THEN- DE
IDENTIFYING THE ESTIMATED
NUMBER CAN BE DONE- OUTSIDE. OF
THIS OFFER AGI TEN. I THANK.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER- CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS A FIVE SET IN THIS
SEAT FOR JUST A FEW YEARS BUT
IN THIS BUILDING FOR ALMOST TEN
YEARS LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
FRIENDS- STOCKTON. AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. I S. IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN A
RESOLUTION THAT ENCOMPASSES ALL
OF THOSE THINGS AND YOU SHOULD
INTRODUCE THAT RESOLUTION SIR
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHORTY- HIS RESOLUTION
DEALS WITH- THE VIETNAM WAR AND
DENOTE IT DEALS WITH THOSE THAT
SERVED VALIANTLY- NEXT TO
AMERICANS FIGHTING IN VIETNAM-
EXCUSE ME CORREA I APOLOGIZE
NOT GET MY CAREER SO CREE WAR
IN AND FIGHTING NEXT TO THEM-
AND ALSO THOSE WHO SERVED IN
THE VIETNAM WAR IS INCLUDED IN
THE RESOLUTION. AND WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME UNITED
STATES CITIZENS AND THEY'RE
LIVING HERE THEY SERVED
ALONGSIDE UNITED STATES
MILITARY WAR HEROES AND- NOW
THEY'RE U. S. CITIZENS AND THEY
ARE HE'S OFFERING THIS
RESOLUTION TO SAY THAT IF THEY
CHOSE TO THEY COULD PETITION TO
BE BURIED IN A NATIONAL
CEMETERY. I REALIZE SIR THAT
YOU ARE HAVING A HUGE CONFLICT
AND MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU
BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY-
THE CITY OF IRVINE IN THE
PEOPLE DOWN IN THAT DISTRICT
THAT YOU REPRESENT WOULD NOT
APPROVE A- CEMETERY THAT IT'S
TAKEN SO MANY YEARS I MEAN I
TOLD YOU ONCE I THINK- TONE
RANCH DONATED THE SITE. WE
IMMEDIATELY GOT IT FIXED WE
HAVE A NATIONAL CEMETERY IN OUR
COMMUNITY I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD
WORK TOGETHER- IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH VETERANS AND IT SHOULDN'T
BE A ONE BUILDER OVER ANOTHER
OR ONE DEVELOPER OVER ANOTHER.
BUT YOU ARE HAVING THAT ISSUE
IN YOUR DISTRICT BUT WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT THAT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOICE
RESOLUTION THAT IS BEFORE US
HERE TODAY. AND I HAVE NEVER
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO JUST.
ADMONISH YOU DON'T MEAN IT LIKE
THAT BUT I KNOW THAT. WE'RE IN
THE MINORITY PARTY REPUBLICANS
BRING A RESOLUTION FOR IT OR A
BILL FORWARD. AND IN ORDER TO
GET IT PASSED YOU HAVE TO TAKE
CERTAIN AMENDMENTS BY THE
MAJORITY PARTY- IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THAT TO-
TAKE WHAT HIS INTENT WAS FOR
THIS PARTICULAR RESOLUTION AND
TRY TO TURN IT INTO SOMETHING
THAT- ALMOST APPEARS- LIKE YOU
ATTACK THIS GENTLEMAN IS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO SAY. YOU SAID NO
AFGHANS NO MEXICANS NO. AND
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF HIS
RESOLUTION. IF YOU HAVE AN
ATTENTIVE RESOLUTION TO INCLUDE
ALL OF THOSE PREVIOUS OR
SUBSEQUENT WARS. THEN INTRODUCE
THAT RESOLUTION HIS RESOLUTION
IS BEFORE US TODAY
SPECIFICALLY. FOR AND THE- YOU
KNOW REPUBLIC OF KOREA VETERANS
WHO SERVED IN THE VIETNAM WAR.
AND SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME UNITED
STATES CITIZENS. M. DOT IS
REPRESENTING HIS DISTRICT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL ARE ELECTED
TO COME HERE TO DO. AND SO. AND
IF YOU WANT TO WORK ON A
RESOLUTION LIKE THAT I'D BE
GLAD TO HELP YOU AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT I COULD DO. ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE. AND TO YOU
KNOW HELP. US SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR DISTRICT
THAT I KNOW YOUR HEART
STRUGGLES WITH BECAUSE- AS
UNITED STATES MILITARY VETERAN.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME WHY WE
CAN'T SOLVE THAT PROBLEM M. AND
I'D BE WILLING TO HELP I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HERE JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO IS- WAS APPROPRIATE
ANYWAY. I'D BE GLAD TO MOVE
YOUR BILL. I HOPE YOUR BILL
PASSES- BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
VALUABLE AND SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD SIR. THANK YOU
CENTER GROUP CENTER NEWMAN FIVE
I'M SORRY EGGMAN BUT I GUESS
AND I AND I AND I AGAIN I HEAR
MIKE MIKE MY COLLEAGUE. FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND KERN COUNTY-
AND UNDERSTAND AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THE STRUGGLE BUT I BUT I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT- AS AS I'VE
HEARD FROM. DID MY COLLEAGUES
OFTENTIMES ABOUT WHY WE'RE
GONNA ELEVATE ONE GROUP OVER
ANOTHER AND WITH THAT THEN
POTENTIALLY. DISCOURAGE OTHERS
FROM SERVING SIDE BY SIDE AND
WE KNOW RIGHT NOW WE HAVE.
SITUATIONS OF THE INTERPRETERS
WHEN IT IT- YOU KNOW FROM WHERE
WE GONNA PUT PEOPLE AT SO. I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT I FEEL
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY WHICH IS AN ELEVATE ONE
GROUP OVER ANOTHER AND THEN WE
HAVE THE ISSUE AS AS THE-
CENTER HAS POINTED OUT- AROUND
AROUND SCARCITY- SO I KNOW. IT
SEEMS LIKE THIS MIGHT NEED A
LITTLE BORED MORE WORK BEFORE
IT GOES FOR. INTERVIEWING. I
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL I THINK
ONE OF MY CULTURE REGION BUT
AND IT WOULD BE MY MOTION. OKAY
THAT MOTION OF. MEMBER OF WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SORRY
RESPECTIVELY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
SO JUST MISSED CHECK I CLARIFY
I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS SO TO INCLUDE
KOREANS WHO FOUGHT IN THE
KOREAN WAR WHO NOW U. S.
CITIZENS BAND VIETNAMESE WHO
FOUGHT IN THE VIETNAMESE WAR IN
OUR U. S. CITIZENS THOSE ARE
MOMENTS THAT. I'LL ASK THE
CLERK BUT I BELIEVE WE'RE
ACCEPTED IS THAT RIGHT.
ACTUALLY. YES I REMEMBER N<c.cyan></c>
INTRODUCED HJR THIRTEEN WHICH
PRETTY MUCH HAS THE EXAM
LANGUAGE IT REQUESTS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW
VIETNAMESE SERVICE MEMBERS WHO
FOUGHT DURING THE VIETNAM WAR
AND SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME U. S.
CITIZENS TO ALSO BE ENTERED SO
THERE IS A OF RESOLUTION I WAS
RECENTLY INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND WHEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUT ON AFFAIRS MILITARY
BENEFITS COMMITTEE MY QUESTION
JUST LET THINGS TODAY'S HEARING
THAT'S ALL IT PERTAINS TO I
UNDERSTAND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
IS ACCEPTED. TO AMENDMENTS YES
RIGHT SO I JUST WANT TO STAND
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON SO AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WE'RE VOTING ON A
BILL THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
AMENDED TO CLARIFY WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S KOREAN VETERANS WHO
BECAME U. S. CITIZENS WHO
SERVED IN COUNTRY THAT'S
AMENDMENT NUMBER ONE VERSUS
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR THAT'S
AMENDMENT NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO TO INCLUDE KOREAN. VETERANS
WHO FOUGHT DURING THE KOREAN
WAR THAT'S THE MOMENT TO MOMENT.
THREE IS VIETNAMESE. MEMBERS OF
THE VIETNAM MILITARY WHO ARE
NOW. CURRENTLY U. S. CITIZENS
THOSE AND THAT'S MY UNDERSTAND
THREE AMENDMENTS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI- ACCEPTED JUST SO
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
OKAY ALL RIGHT. ARE ARE DONE OR
NOT BE DUPLICATIVE OR IF THERE
WAS ALREADY A SEPARATE THE
RESOLUTION INTRODUCED TOUGH FOR
VIETNAM'S SOLDIERS WHO CAME
HERE THERE'S NO PURPOSE OF
WALKING INCORPORATING HERE ARE
BECAUSE- ASSEMBLY MANAT JANET
YEAH AND- PROBABLY INTRODUCED A
SIMILAR CONTACTS A FULL VIETNAM
SOLDIERS. WHICH SEEMS SORT CLUB
WAS THE WILL. VERIFY YOUR
SPEAKS THAT- I HEARD TOO BUT
YOU HEARD. THREE- NUMBER ONE IS
THE- THE KOREAN- VETERANS SICK
THOSE WHO FOUGHT IN KOREA. YES
WILL BE INCLUDED. RIGHT THAT'S
ONE AND OF COURSE THE CARIBBEAN
WHO FOUGHT ALONGSIDE OUR
MILITARY IN VIETNAM IN COUNTRY-
WILL BE INCLUDED. RIGHT I MEAN
DO YOU INTERPRET WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE AMENDMENT
SAID YOU'RE GOING TO ACCEPT.
YOU AGREE WITH. YEAH ARE YOU
ARE YOU AGREE TO A DESKTOP BOB
THIS ORIGIN ON AGL'S CURRENT
LAWS SELL. KOREAN SOLDIERS WHO
SERVED IN VIETNAM AND WHO
BECAME NATURALIZED US CITIZEN.
SOLDIER CONTRIBUTIONS TO
RESOLVED IT DOES SAY REPUBLIC
OF KOREA VETERANS. WHO SERVED
IN THE VIETNAM WAR. WHAT THE
ALREADY IN I THINK SHOULD
NUMBER WAS REALLY WANTED
WHETHER THAT WAS IN OR DURING
TIME PERIOD TO CORRECT. THE
THIS IS MY UNDER. SO THAT WE
ARE ON THE SAME SHEET MUSIC
THAT THERE ARE THREE AMENDMENTS
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
ORIGINALLY ACCEPTED I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE STATUS IS NOW.
AMENDMENT ONE. IS THAT. IT'S
CLARIFIED THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. KOREAN SOLDIERS WHO
SERVED IN THE COUNTRY OF
VIETNAM DURING THE VIETNAM
CONFLICT AS OPPOSED TO THOSE IS
CENTER NEWMAN POINTED OUT WHO
SIMPLY SERVED DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR SO THAT'S THAT'S
AMENDMENT ONE. IN MY THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE ORIGIN. LONG RIDGE OF
THIS. ON. TEN IT SHOULD I FIVE
I DON'T SEE THAT BUT IF YOU CANPOINT THAT OUT THAT'S GREAT
KNOW WHAT I MEAN THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF BRIDGING TEN
SOMETHING THE LOS CLOSER. IN
THE. LET ME ENTER GENTLEMAN
WE'RE GONNA CALL RESET WOULDN'T.
IT WITH. THE BILL IT WILL BE IN
RECESS JUST MY- MISTER CHAIR
BEFORE WEEK RESET LET'S. LET'S
SET THE- SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE JUST. ONE THOSE WHO
SERVED IN THE CAR VIETNAM TO.
THOSE WHO SERVED DURING THE
KOREAN CONFLICT AS WELL AND
THREE VIETNAMESE SOLDIERS OR
MILITARY PERSONNEL WHO SERVED
AND OUR US CITIZENS THOSE OF
THE THREE AMENDMENTS. AGO IN
RECESS THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S
CONTINUE WITH THE MEETING ONCE
AGAIN LAYS IN GERMAN- WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS A. J. R. TEN AND WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WE'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THE WAY IT
IS WRITTEN ANY AMENDMENTS WILL
BE TAKEN ON THE FLOOR IN THE
FUTURE BUT WE'RE GOING TO VOTE
ON YOUR BILL. ON THE RESOLUTION
RATHER THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN.
SURE ALL RIGHT OKAY IT FALL
YEAH I DAHLE ORIGINALLY. WANTED
TO BECOME MORE EMBRACE CIVIL
INCLUSIVE FIVE SUGGESTED TOPIC
HAS SOME FRIENDLY. FRIEND YOU
COULD YOU COULD NOT GET IN THE
FUTURE YEAH YOUR MIND WHATEVER
IT WILL GO IT IS UPDATING
COMPLICATED US ALL I THINK BFSI.
FOR ME TO- CHANGE MY MIND AND
THE DEAL WITH YES ARE JUST A
THEM AND OF SEPARATELY. AND
DUST WITH MY- LANGUAGE WOULD BE
MUCH SAID THAT IS CORRECT WE
ARE NOT TAKING ANY AMENDMENTS
WE'RE GOING WITH THE ORIGINAL.
OF THE RESOLUTION WHICH
WRITTEN. AND AENDMENTS TO BE
TAKEN UP ON THE FLOOR YES OUR
RIGHT NOW I COULD NOT REMEMBER
MOTION FOR ME I JUST I WILL
MOVE THE BILL AYE AYE I ALSO
WANT TO SAY- TO ASSEMBLY CHOI I
DO APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE- DIET DIE
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU'VE DONE
THIS BOTH IN GOOD FAITH AND
WITH GOOD HUMOR- I SALUTE YOU
AS WELL FOR YOUR SERVICE. I'M
SO GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL TODAY.
MMO ON THE FLOOR. IN BEFORE THE
ROLL I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE
MY COMMENT I THANK YOU FOR.
COMING BEFORE US WITH THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO AS I SAID TAKE
TAKE UP THE MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE. AND ALL OF US ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT. THOSE WHO
SERVED WITH US THOSE WHO. GAVE
THEIR LIVES. TO OF OUR GREAT
COUNTRY AND AS ALLIES. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE BILL SO WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT UP NOW. SO
I HAVE A MOTION FLOOR. AND- A
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AJ ARE TEN THE
MOTION AS BE ADOPTED. ARCHULETA
I WHAT I'D GROWTH HI GROW BY
EGGMAN MELENDEZ NEWMAN I HUMAN
AYE ROTH- BURKE. WE HAVE THREE
THERE'LL BE. THREE ZERO FIVE
THE NOSE ZERO. OKAY WE WILL
CONTINUE ON WITH THE NEXT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBER. IT
NOW FOR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO- GOOD MORNING NO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO
WOULD AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA'S
MILITARY DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM
INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF
AND IN CONSULTATION WITH OUR
STATE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES OR L. E. ASE. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PROTECTNG THE
CYBERSECURITY OF THE STATE
SCHOOLS CYBERSECURITY THREATS
ARE A COMMON REALITY TODAY AND
HAVE BECOME AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION FOR ALL
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
ESPECIALLY AMID A PANDEMIC THAT
HAS SHIFTED MANY IN PERSON
OPERATIONS TO ONLINE. IT'S THE
ENTITIES THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
THIS SHIFT MORE DRAMATICALLY
THAN ANY OTHERS ARE
CALIFORNIA'S ELEAZAR WITH
SCHOOLS BEING FORCED TO
INSTANTANEOUSLY SHIFT FROM IN
CLASS LEARNING TO REMOTE
LEARNING. BOB SOULES CAR
SCHOOLS ARE GRADUALLY RETURNING
TO REGULAR IN CLASS LEARNING
YET THEY HAVE INVESTED IN
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE
THEIR STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES CAN LIKELY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO THESE
INVESTMENTS WHICH INCLUDE
CONNECTED TECHNOLOGY LIKE
TABLETS ARE CRITICAL TO
LEARNING TO THE LEARNING
PROCESS NEVERTHELESS ST STE
THIS TECHNOLOGY. CAN COME WITH
CYBER SECURITY THREATS. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY TO ADDRESS THE
CYBER SECURITY CONCERNS BY
ALLOWING THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE ALLEY ACE THE ASSESSMENTS
WILL BE CONFIDENTIAL AND PAID
FOR BY THE REQUESTING LTA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
AND HERE TO TESTIFIED BY PHONE
TODAY. HIS ANDREA BENNETT FROM
CALIFORNIA I T. IN EDUCATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO- ANYONE- WANTED
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- AGAIN
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED
THREE MINUTES FOR PRIMARY
SUPPORT AND OR OPPOSITION
FOLLOW THE TUITION TO TESTIFY
MUCH LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME FILIATION A POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. MODERATOR
PLEASE RELEASE THE LINE FOR THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS- ANDREA
BENNETT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA I. T. IN EDUCATION-
ANDREW BENNETT ARE YOU THERE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANDREA
BENNETT AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA IT IN
EDUCATION. WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING THE I.
T. PROFESSIONAL TO WORK AND
SCHOOL I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO FOR OFFERING A
SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LAND LEGISLATION. THE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN CONTINUALLY EXPANDING FOR
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY WITH THIS
INCREASE IN TECHNOLOGY USES IN
YOUR STATE HAS COME A SIMILAR
INCREASE IN CYBER SECURITY
THREATS. ALLEN HAS ONLY BECOME
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AT SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA RAPIDLY.
DEPLOYED LEARNING MODELS FOR
STUDENTS. AT WORK ON OUR
ABILITIES ALSO INCREASED. THE
FIRST STEP IN HELPING MITIGATE
THE THREATS OF IDENTIFYING
VULNERABILITIES UNFORTUNATELY
HAVING A PRIVATE OR THIRD PARTY
ENTITY PERFORMANCE
CYBERSECURITY AUDIT CAN BE
EXTREMELY COSTLY. MANY ALLEY A
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES EITHER ACCURATELY
ASSESS THEIR OWN NETWORK OR
CREATE WITH AN AGENCY TO DO SO
OR CONTRACTORS. AN AGENCY TO DO
SO. THIS BILL TAKES AT SOLVING
ISSUE AND AUTHORIZED THE NOISE
APART AT REQUIRE I'VE BEEN
ALLEY A- PERFORMING A SECURITY
I OF THE L. I. IT ALSO IN THAT
THE A. H. WORK WITHIN THE APART
ON THE- OF THE AUDIT AND MAKES
CLEAR THE- OF THE AUDIT ARE
DISCLOSED ONLY TO THE L. A-
ARTICLE MANAGE. ST DATA. FOR
SOCIAL SECURITY NOW CAN.
RECORDS EIGHTY THIRTEEN FIFTY
RECORD A SMALL BIT AND STEP.
TOWARD HELPING SECURE AND
PROTECT THIS DATA WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- NOW WILL MOVE IN TO
FURTHER TESTIMONY- ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO ALL THREE
TESTS FIND SUPPORT. I SEE NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY PORTION TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
TWO. I SEE NONE. LET'S CONTINUE
ON MODERATOR- IF WE CAN NOW GO
ON TO THE LINE XIN ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY TO OPEN THE
LUNCH. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO MEMBERS CONNECTED IN SUPPORT
SIR. MODERATOR A NEW PROMPT
THEM ONE MORE TIME IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO.
CERTAINLY WHAT AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER IT IS PRESSING ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IMMEDIATELY.
WE HAVE NO LINE'S QUEUING AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CAN WIN- WISHING NOW TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. I SEE
NONE ANYONE WITH THIS IMMUNE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHICH IN TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO. I SEE NONE-
MODERATOR I THINK THAT'LL DO IT
FOR YOU WE WILL NOW SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO IS- WAITING
IN LINE TO CHECK ONE MORE IME
BEFORE WE CLOSE IT OUT IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER MATTERS
PRESSING ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF IN Q.
IMMEDIATELY IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO LINES DOING AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU LET
ME TURN IT OVER THE MEMBERS NOW
CENTERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IF THE BILL. OKAY
CENTER GROVE MOTION MOVE THE
BILL. AND- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO. I ASKED WHERE I WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ARCHULETA I GROWTH.
HI EGGMAN MELENDEZ NEWMAN ROTH
NUMBER. THANKS BYE. M. THREE
ZERO NOT BE ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OKAY WILL COME
BACK. WHEN WE SHOULD WAIT.
YEAH
COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS AND WILL GO ON RECESS
THANK YOU.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND A
CONSULTANT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START WITH THE ROLL CALL. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE VOTE
IS CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI GROVE. GROVE I
ROTH HI SIX ZERO THIRTY BILLS
OUT. THANK YOU- THE TO GO BACK
TO A. B. YOU HAVE. SIX ZERO THE
BUILD UP OKAY CAN WE WANT TO AB
ONE ZERO ZERO TWO. AND AJ ARE.
TEN OKAY. OKAY AB TEN- TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
ROTH AB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO AB
ONE ZERO ZERO TWO. ROTH I. SIX
ZERO. SIX ZERO BILL GOES OUT.
NEXT ONE AJ ARE TEN THE MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED. CURRENT BEAU IS
THREE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING HI EGGMAN.
BROTH. THREE ZERO WE WILL
CONTINUE IT WAS THREE ZERO.
THANK YOU RECONSIDERATION
RECONSIDERATION OKAY. RIGHT
WITH THAT GO AHEAD AND CLOSE.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING HI THE VOTE IS CURRENTLY
THREE ZERO EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
NEWMAN. HUMAN AYE ROTH. ROTH
AYE MELENDEZ. ABOUT THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU WE GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THANK YOU ALL STAFF
EVERYONE- PUT TIME AND EFFORT
IN THE HEARING TODAY TO PUT IT
TOGETHER. AND I THINK YOU OF
THOSE WHO CALLED AND WITH YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN. IN THE FUTURE
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN PATIENTS
TODAY- WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON MILITARY VETERANS. AFFAIRS
IS HEREBY ADJOURNED. ALL.